[Applause]
happy Wednesday everybody uh yes you are
amazing
what a glorious Wednesday it is for one
Chicago mayor Lori Lightfoot seen here
having her prostate checked
became Chicago's first incumbent mayor
in 40 years to lose re-election
congrats Lori
she deserves it because she broke
another glass ceiling she was the first
black lesbian mayor of Chicago but now
she's the worst mayor ever which sadly
means no black lesbian Mayors for a
while in Chicago way to ruin it for them
Nero
she got roughly 17 percent of the vote
so even if her fan base from the Cook
County Jail population all 5700 of them
voted still wasn't enough losing a
former head of Chicago Public School
Paul vallis and Cook County Commissioner
Brandon Johnson they took 34 and 20
percent of the vote respectively and
will now head to a runoff on to
determine the next mayor that was boring
does I should have just cut all that out
we didn't care about those numbers
my fault
but now now this is supposedly good news
but why is it news at all it shouldn't
be news when the worst mayor in the
country loses this should be expected
but it wasn't why is that well it's be
it's news that you lost despite having
more protection than a Fort Knox full of
condoms
Lightfoot was a historical verse of
course first black female lesbian
Chicago mayor perhaps also a garden
gnome a woodland nymph a magical imp a
Ghost of Christmas Past Medusa
but because of that the media cut her
more slack than a tailor on meth
but as we found out you can't just run a
city into the ground and then accuse
people of racism and misogyny once those
people find out you suck which is
exactly what you did after she lost
blamed it on the voters for being racist
when a reporter asked if she'd been
treated unfairly she answered quote I'm
a black woman in America of course
yeah that makes sense racist sexist
homophobes gave her a chance to be mayor
but only once
so now she chalks up her loss to
fictitious white supremacists she's like
a masculine version of Jessie Smollett
foreign
of course her loss is a win for Chicago
and a lesson for everyone else in
politics so are you listening Eric Adams
Karen bass London breed Muriel Bowser
Ted wheeler Jacob Frye maybe voters in a
deep blue City finally said this
experiment with dangerous infantile
lefties is finally over and Ticking
boxes only creates more boxes except we
call them coffins
true if you're Progressive and want to
set some records while in office make
sure it isn't for number of murders
under her the city's homicide rate Rose
to its highest numbers in 25 years they
haven't seen that many Slaughters since
Michael Jordan was thin
the city saw 695 murders in 2022 and 804
in 2021. so I did some math at that pace
if Lori got elected for four more years
at the end of her second term Chicago's
population will be the same as
Gilligan's Island
laughs
right now if you're a kid in Chicago
you're just as likely to go outside and
catch a bullet as you are a cold
anyway here's her concession speech
we fought the right fights and we put
this city on a better path I'm grateful
that we work together to remove a record
number of guns off our streets reduce
homicides and started making real
progress on public safety
so she reduced murders under her watch
but only after she presided over an
explosion in murders under her watch
that's like Biden saying gas costs
slightly fewer arms and legs
that makes sense anyway I haven't seen I
haven't seen someone that delusional
since Rachel Levine tried on a two-piece
but I'm sure she'll land on her feet
it's hard not to when you wear a size
14.
[Laughter]
and a homeless guy's head
but
but lefties always get another job if
she's not teaching at Harvard she'll be
a spokesperson for Spirit Halloween
[Laughter]
of course the bigger question is will
other Democrat Mayors with cities
overrun by crime take note of Lightfoot
getting the boot we do know that several
Democratic Mayors are finally waking up
to doing something about homelessness
committing the deranged to treatment
meanwhile others are distancing
themselves from the defund the police
movement like it's MS-13 with monkey pox
so ironically the woke is finally
getting a wake-up call let's hope they
don't hit the snooze button because
people are tired of being dead to put it
another way they're dead tired of
incompetence being protected by
diversity and they don't want a mayor
that reminds you of Beetlejuice
[Laughter]
further proof
I used to do that
further proof she steals her pants off
shopping mall security guards
yeah
tonight's guests
[Applause]
she talks so fast sign language
interpreters get Hazard pay opposed to
the new podcast Fox True Crime Emily
compagna
[Applause]
his marriage is like a tornado as it
ends with him losing his house actor
writer and comedian Jamie Lista
her pronouns are Boo and who Fox News
contributor captive
yeah
and when life gives him lemons life
regrets it my massive sidekick in the
NWA World Heavyweight Champion Tyrus
[Applause]
Emily I go to your first because you're
sitting there
um
saying we did this and we did that in
our concession speech but it was never
there was never I got the impression
there was never a we it was always a her
and she was always battling everybody
and remember when those emails were
leaked to the Press they were filled
with literally dozens of abusive emails
on her part to the staff so you're right
that her we didn't even include those
that signed up that believed in her
cause that believed in this black
lesbian mayor of Chicago that was going
to have historical first instead they
gained historical statistics that ran
that City into the ground you know I
love that you brought up the boxes in
the coffins because she was called a
political rock star in the beginning and
she utterly failed at her job and to me
that that illustrates the current
situation right now which is the left
props up these people that check certain
boxes oh they're going to be amazing and
then she absolutely abdicated her duty
to keep those residents safe and for
someone that said that she is so
committed to Black American causes why
then were the single most affected
victims of that homicide rate young
African-American boys they are children
slaughtered as an epidemic under her
watch and that's what the people in her
city called it you know she said at the
end I'll will be remembered for what we
we accomplished and how hard we worked
the the effort that we did on behalf of
Chicagoans and damn right because you
did nothing you know it's interesting
and it's kind of sad and pathetic that
she won the nomination for mayor with
the same percentage so it just shows you
how Screwed Up Chicago is 70 she won 17
now she loses Jamie you're a person
who's faced an unbelievable amount of
humiliation and loss
what is your advice for Lori Lightfoot
who's going through some suffering of
her own nothing like what you went
through but I mean
yeah and think about the humiliation and
loss just from being on this show
nice you know nice
I don't know I think she has is it
possible these murderers are racist and
they're only killing people because
she's a black lesbian mayor
could there be less guns because you
remove them when they're next to a dead
body
um
it's all crazy and I'm I think the um
and the other story here about like
removing by the way numbers can't lie I
mean that's basically the bottom line
here is like I was in Chicago and
actually heard two murderers going I
don't think we can follow this next year
um we got to back it off like those
numbers don't lie this she's a terrible
mayor
um but I'm also the whole getting rid of
the um committing homeless people
without you know them volunteer I think
we have to start doing this uh I think
you can pretty easily tell who I was
walking today and I saw a guy doing he
was doing like a three-card Monty is
that what it's called yes homeless guy
clearly crazy and he was like doing a
magic trick and I was thinking like oh
my God that's gonna be the hardest
person to capture is like a homeless
magician
because em
put a straight jacket on him all of a
sudden I'm wearing the straight jacket
he's handcuffed I'm handcuffed to a pole
um
I don't know I just it's it's just it's
so dangerous everywhere man I think
homeless people some of them could get
rid of their signs right like I saw one
guy saying the sign said like need help
and I was like you're wearing boots and
I could see all 10 of your toes I know
uh cat
um
are you gonna miss her yeah yeah
she was like horrible but sometimes
you're so horrible that that makes you
kind of awesome yeah
do you remember that whole Scandal
because she said she had the biggest in
Chicago right
that was awesome it was awesome
jokes if she would have made that her
slogan Lori Lightfoot biggest dick in
Chicago
you're not gonna vote with for somebody
who has a smaller so
I think that she could have won that way
yeah and I just think it's great that
she's not sad she really thinks it's
racism sexism homophobia that is the
reason she lost which is I think that
would be great to feel that way yeah
instead of like when you lose just think
it's because like you know you're not
good enough you never will be yeah
um to not have to blame anybody or blame
everybody by yourself but she's right
about one thing which she said she put
the city on a better path which probably
she did by losing yeah that's true Tyrus
um is this really like a victory for
people when it's basically she just lost
the two other Democrats if she were up
against a republican the scary part is
she would probably still have won that's
what frightened it makes no no I think
and to cat's Point
um she did lose for being the biggest in
Chicago
it was just
being used as a pronoun as opposed to
the actual appendage see the thing is
though she lost for the same reasons
that she was elected she the same things
that she's complaining about are the
same reasons why she was put in no one
ever bothered to check her resume and
when you when you take somebody based on
how they look and who they sleep with
you forget this little thing called
character
education and commitment to the job into
which we saw during the entire time
because it was a sound bite every week
how she mismanaged every possible
situation because she was never
qualified for the job other than she
fell the part and a bunch of racist they
it's polite racism when you want to prop
somebody up in a position because they
checked the Box Knowing damn right well
they're going to fail but this here's
the thing about having someone like that
in your office is there a puppet they'll
do what you tell them to do you pay you
pay their back taxes you help them get
any take care of old problems you get
rid of bad relations you do all these
things for these people with horror
character that and we know she has
Horrible character because we saw her
track record this isn't rocket scientist
or whatever but uh so yeah she lost for
the reason why she got put in so yeah we
have she was vastly under qualified and
and it showed yeah you know what we have
to go I know we have to go but like if
you Nev we did a sec didn't we do a
segment on her Yelp review she rented a
limo it's the best if you ever want to
get an insight into her brain she left a
Yelp review for a limo company and she
was upset that the limo driver had used
the bathroom yes it's one of the best
it's one of the best written
derangement things you will ever see
it's just like it's like it's it's
Madness so just Google or go to Yelp but
just put her name in there and it'll pop
up I'm sure she had an opinion on
everything that didn't go her way yeah
exactly it was always somebody else's
fault hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else